so hello everybody i am delighted to be
here with aiden hart aidan hart is an
iconographer he is a writer
um
and for me it's very personal because
he's also let's say uh someone who came
before me as an icon carver someone
someone who represented icon carving to
an orthodox world that that had
forgotten a little bit about that
tradition and so earlier very early in
my own career i reached out to aiden you
know for advice and for criticism he was
always very gracious to give it but uh
beyond that he has written several books
on iconography i would say the the bible
of iconography um
and uh and he's also written about
theory he's done so many things and so
i'm very delighted and grateful to have
him uh with me today
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
aden thank you for coming to talk to us
thank you jonathan thank you for the
honor of finally having time with you i
guess i've known you so well through our
correspondence here face to face
virtually
virtually exactly
actually
yeah several years ago i had the hope of
you know going to england and studying
with you and doing all that things but
you know then then reality of being with
the family and trying to set up a
carving practice hits you uh very hard
but um maybe tell people a little bit
about your your story because you are in
a way a precursor to many of us
being some you know one of after
uspensky and that kind of very first
seed of iconography you were one of the
first people to
plunge in completely into the world of
icons of sacred art and representing it
to the world so i i want people to know
a little bit about how you came to where
you are
thank you i um did my degree in english
literature and
also mathematics
i've always loved the arts and the
sciences and this actually played out
quite well later on when i became an
iconographer and then i changed the
teacher and left that quite quickly to
follow my
my heart feeling be a sculptor um
so i i was in a heineken church so i was
aware of the role of art in general that
in my sculpting i was searching for ways
of showing the inner as well as the
outer eyes we're interested in bringing
together
the spiritual and the material and i was
looking for art that would help me do
this and i came to some conclusions how
to unite the two and then a friend of
mine in new zealand i was raised in new
zealand i just visited two orthodox
monks in new zealand one of whom was an
iconographer so i um i went and visited
these monks and immediately i saw the
icon i realized that the icon i've been
doing for two thousand years almost what
i had been trying to do in my own little
sculpting work and um
plus a lot more of course and then i was
really drawn to the monastic life and
realized that behind the whole icon
culture was
a way of seeing a way of seeing the
world where you seeing god
so to cut a long story short i became
orthodox and
ended up coming to england i was born in
england
though raised in new zealand so it
wasn't a problem settling here
and because i had been a sculptor before
i became orthodox and actually started
carving and then my parish priest
suggested i also start to learn to paint
icons and it all grew from there really
um i was able to to go full time pretty
soon which allowed me to
dedicate my whole life to
iconography which to me is a form of
prayer as well it's not just being an
artist it's i've always been interested
in mission as well about
knowing god as well as i can but also
communicating that to others and i
noticed
through the icon all sorts of doors open
like i've given talks at the british
library and places like that where you
could never be asked to talk about
christ but you couldn't talk about icons
apart from
uh talking about christ in the secular
setups everything just fell into place
very nicely all these different parts i
mean that had been a little bit separate
orders naturally found together
and you also at the beginning of of your
work you also spent several years on
marathons living as a monk for several
years maybe tell us a bit about how that
fit into your work as well
that's right i was very i'd always been
attracted to the monastic life even
before i became orthodox
and my original original intention was
to join the monks in new zealand as an
office but while i was overseas they
suggested i traveled overseas of it
before returning to them things changed
for them they had to move into the city
to look after parish so i stayed in
england and there was a nun in the
parish i was in and um so a lot of
monastic services
um
and i really wanted to join a monastery
in the english-speaking world but at
that stage the door wasn't open at
saints of phony's monastery
so um
i thought well poppy athos is the only
place i went to greece to study modern
greek first bishop callisto's my
spiritual father suggested that i
studied the language first so i was
taking one step at a time and really
intended to go to athos slightly with
the sadden heart because i really wanted
to be in the english-speaking world
so after studying for a year i went to
run back to england to arrange my
affairs and um ended up staying with
father barnabas the welsh monk and
joined timberson office
um
and so i was him with that three years
and then i think he found it hard to
have people with them he wanted people
but being old and that he found it hard
so
the bishop said well it seems you've got
to move on from there and land was
bought in news in england for me to be a
hermit
but it was at that point my archbishop
sent me to mount athos for training not
to stay there but for training
before settling as a hermit here so i
say about i don't know just over a year
and a half with
my beloved abbott there father vasilius
um of him of entry
and i've been came back and lived as a
hermit for about six years but every
year went back for about a month to
verdon monastery which was my monastery
at athos
um so for six years i would say living
as a hermit but in fact
as i say jokingly to people if you want
to live a quiet life don't be a hermit
people find out about lisa herman on the
hill let's go and visit him so it's a
pretty tiring and social life sometimes
one of the things you right sorry
no i because i was i was trying to
think about some of the things you
talked about in terms of uh wanting to
be in the english-speaking world and i
think this is something with really
which
really characterizes your work as an
iconographer is a desire to both meld
into the universal tradition you could
say the universal imagery of iconography
but also
try to
adapt it to transform it or to connect
it let's say to the place where you are
let's say the english-speaking world its
own tradition and try to connect it i
think that's one of the most important
aspects of your work and maybe tell
people a little bit why you think that's
important to do
yes thank you it's true right from the
beginning i thought well christ was
incarnate on earth and not just kindness
in the world in general
but um the whole christian life i think
is
extension of an incarnation so yeah i'm
british i'm not from from greece um you
know greece has in many ways retain that
icon tradition but
i feel my job as a christian is not just
to introduce byzantine into britain
but to um
resurrect the the icon traditional
britain um so i think it's both
theological but also pastoral i think if
people think that orthodoxy is
an exotic import
from greece then it's not really
reflecting life with christ um
accurately you know life is with christ
me aid in heart as a as a personal as a
personal experience and i'm i'm british
i'm not i'm not greek
um
so i think
it's theologically it's really important
and also historically um it's always
happened that the icon tradition has
gradually expressed itself in a unique
way it always struck me how russian
russian churches initially were quite
byzantine they had a rounded dome but
then gradually they developed the onion
dome
partially perhaps practical reasons to
shed the snow but partially they felt
that that expressed their experience of
god
more accurately than around the dome
they extended the drum they did all
sorts of things it's identifiably
orthodox but it's russian you wouldn't
get that and by stand him
um so
fortunately in britain we have a long
tradition of of of early sacred art that
is in the orthodox sort of ethos um the
romanesque in particular to my mind so
quite often if it's appropriate i i've
drawn on that so for example the church
where my parishes
um it's a 7th century 8th century
foundation the church itself is about
13th 14th century so when i fresco the
east wall
i drew heavily on some um
illuminated manuscripts uh from what's
called the berry saint evan gospel
uh it wasn't hopefully pastiche wasn't
just a straight copy but it was clearly
influenced by that so when people visit
it they realize actually this church is
orthodox but it's also british you know
the iconography reflects that
and what is your approach because i
think this is my one of my big concerns
is to create something which is
uh both traditional completely
traditional completely soaking in the
language that has been given to us but
also like you said not a pastiche or not
uh something which is a nostalgic piece
of art and it's it seems difficult to
find the line between the two but i'm
wondering if if what is the approach
that you have to be able to create
something which is both traditional and
authentic at the same time
i think it's an enormous challenge in in
some ways we can say that the icon
tradition has revived after a time of
decadency for like both in greece and
byzantium but i think we're still
incredibly immature
as a sort of a
uh orthodox iconographic culture that we
don't really understand the timeless
principles well enough to do this well i
think
people like yourself and the orthodox
arts journal are exactly on the right
track and that we know what you're
trying to do but i think it's take a few
decades for us to really understand
those timeless principles so as you say
we're
living within the tradition
uh we're locked in your pastiche we're
doing some something that's authentic
but to do that we need to not only just
know in our hedge those timeless
principles and therefore what can be
changed adapted but we've got to be in
it so i think i feel myself i'm
still learning a second language you
know it's not my first language so
though i'm i'm happy with some of the
things i've done i'm so aware that i'm
i'm speaking a second language so i
think the first thing this is to be
intelligent you know not not to be
scared not to
think oh yeah i've got a copy something
from
moscow 15th century
iconography if i do anything else i
might get all decadent yeah for the rest
of my life i'll copy these i made them
harder and do my own thing you know
that's the other extreme but both
extremes i think are extremes
so i think it needs a lot of
intelligence to sort of think well you
know actually what is essential
um and and what can i draw from my own
culture that is usable i was talking to
one of my students yesterday who's not
from norway my husband's an orthodox
priest
and hannah was thinking of doing a
doctorate on um how to develop say an
icon screen appropriate for norway drawn
on the norwegian
folk tradition of amazing folk patterns
they paint on the wooden churches and
i've got the stave churches the state
church as a stand probably doesn't
express the orthodox liturgy well enough
but one can start with that and then
adapt it
so i think the more more people thinking
like this they'll be fully in the
tradition but love the culture feel that
a lot needs to be redeemed and completed
and and show that you know christ is in
china now in norway or brisbane or
canadore in the u.s
yeah and i think this is what you said
is is very important because there's a
we have a tendency to have a kind of
duality which is on the one hand we
we we find people who are really
attached to their culture almost in like
in a nationalistic sense and they feel
like this is the the thing they need to
grab onto in order to to survive you
know in this this chaotic world uh so we
have this extreme and then the other
extreme we find are people who want to
deny all particularities and and see it
as suspicious you know see it as
idolatrous and everything um and it it
seems like
this breathing in and breathing out
let's say between how god is the source
of our identity but that we have to be
careful not to
be attached to these secondary
identities but see them through the
lands of christ let's say and that's
when they actually take their
their full color that's when their their
true colors appear and their true value
appears is when they're submitted to
something higher submitted to something
which is beyond it um and i know you've
had some insights into that let's say in
terms of
in terms of of iconography um and so
as
i'm sorry i'm a bit selfish because i'm
asking this in a way that just for me
you know
there is a temptation also this is a
temptation that i have i don't know if
it's a temptation or if it's a if it's
an appropriate desire because we live in
a world where we have all these images
we can we can go online we can find
images from you know the catacombs to
russia to greece and everything
it's difficult not to have this mosaic
in the back of our minds you know as as
we as we work and so and for myself also
living in america where
we have this strange collage of culture
so i'm french right my first language is
french but i live in canada and you know
i live in america with all this
english-speaking world um and so there's
also
in me at least there's a desire to
create something which is synthetic is
the only way to say it which is
particular but also draws not only from
let's say i would
draw from the french romanesque or from
but also kind of pulling in little
threads from from the scandinavian world
you know from even from coptic icons and
pulling them together to create
something which is moving towards
synthesis so i don't know if there's
something of that that you find that if
you find it's a dangerous way of working
or if you think that it has some value
that's a really good really important
point you're making jonathan because
as with most things a strength is a
potential weakness
but the fact is we do live in a world
where all these different icon styles
traditions
are available and
even impinge themselves on us whether or
not we like exposed to all these things
so it's a fact we can't pretend that
it's not a fact so i think we've got to
be real and think well this is going to
affect us and that's a good thing so the
next question is how to make it
authentic um you know how to
um
have it become within a living
experience from within a living
experience rather than just just being
gluing together arbitrarily
how to do that
i really think ultimately it's only
living the life of christ and the church
so you've got that sort of music we have
that music of heaven in us
and it's only while we're making all
these millions of decisions when you're
carving something painting something
designing it
if you little
choice we make
it's got to consciously or unconsciously
be decided against that music within us
that that that um experience of the life
of christ and if it jars with that
enemies you think no
i'll leave that to say but if it
corresponds with that
then we can use that element of norway
or egypt whatever um i don't think
there's any
um formula we we can use
and i i think it's just living that life
in the in the community of the church
living a life of prayer because in the
end literal arts got to support worship
and awe
and thankfulness and joy and humility
and compunction and as we experience
that ourselves we'll make the wrong
decisions
so i think i think in summary
we do live in this post-modern age
we exposed all these things and i think
it's only natural
um whether or not we do it consciously
unconsciously that what we make is going
to be affected by that but we've got to
measure it against that experience of
prayer does it support it does it
support
the right virtues or does it
make us noisy inside and confuse us
and so i mean that brings me also to
another thing that i've at least
experienced in myself as i'm working
because there is also
a desire to be
you know let's say how how can i say
this there's a desire to impress in the
sense that we want like i want to make
the best image possible
and i'm always on a line between you
know making something which is amazing
uh so that i can impress others and then
saying to myself that i'm doing it for
the glory of god
um but it's not always true right it's
like sometimes i i just i just know that
if i do it this way it's going to it's
going to be it's going to be impressive
uh and so for me at least you know in in
light of what you said i think i
struggle with that quite a bit as well
trying to
uh to find the balance between being
technically proficient
and having something which kind of
embodies this music or this kind of
living music that you that you talk
about um
yes and this is one thing that father
vasilius the albert of aviron
taught me he had this lovely term
there's a perfect imperfection and that
imperfect perfection
so and there was a wonderful exhibition
of
byzantine icons that came to the world
academy in england a while back and
in the very last room there are quite a
few icons from sinai
um festival icons i remember in
particular from about the 12th century
what struck me
was how free and messy they were and at
the same time incredibly beautiful and
you get the impression that the person
who painted just like a prophet and the
word of god was in the soul and burning
in the soul and you just had to get it
out he wasn't too bothered about you
know putting every two now then and that
was done with great skill it's exported
skill but they weren't bothered about
the little details the buildings were a
bit wonky
but you felt
the spirit come through whereas i've
seen a lot of icons that are made with
consummate skill but somehow
the skill encrusted the spirit it didn't
embellish the spirit
um so you notice the skill
first and not and not the spirit so
i'm really interested in the approach of
the japanese traditional chinese
painters and i've done a few articles on
um elements of the philosophy of the
painting especially from a book called
the um
mustard seed garden book of painting
and one thing they say there is a
different stages first is to gain great
skill consummates
and the top though
is to discard skill and just
express the the
the lie that the inner essence of things
of course the skill comes through
but um it's like your first language so
you don't have to think about grammar
because it's part of you
so i think a lot of us i mean a lot of
people around who don't even have the
skills they're just really badly painted
icons then you get the next level highly
skilled but
you're weighed down by that skill
the highest level like theopharm the
greek is frescoes there's here's a
prophet speaking the word of the lord
burns out it's a burning bush you're
looking at not a not a topiary bush
bushel nice equipped
so it's that fire we're trying to
communicate um yeah
yeah and you you see i think you know i
there are some artists right now like
that seem to have kind of this internal
i'm thinking about cordless of course
but cordis who has internalized the
language so much
you know that like you said it's not
he's he's not in the second language
anymore it's not something he's learning
he it's become his own inner grammar and
so when he's working
there's
there's both kind of this deep tradition
of the church and there's also an
idiosyncratic aspect to it which is just
him just doing it and when you watch him
draw something and he just goes right in
and there's no sketch and there's no
measuring and it just goes straight
there is something about this chinese
approach where you know
once the skill has been mastered and
centered then there's almost a letting
loose or
yeah there's a capacity to just do
without thinking without planning um and
you almost it's almost suddenly there's
something theological about this idea
too that that the idea of will or
freedom we tend to think of it as
deliberating but if you're truly in this
music you know truly in this kind of
this
this song that you have inside of you
there's no deliberation there's just
action there's just just you know the
a straightforward manifestation let's
say of these higher things
i think there is that but at the same
time there must always be sobriety
and you must be listening more than
speaking artistically because i've had
the blessing of knowing some saints uh
saint pious amid father for furious a
bit same silhouette same
and i noticed um
they wouldn't always answer immediately
you felt that there were tons of things
they couldn't say all of it should be
true technically
but
they would listen and then speak and it
was just precise it was just just the
right thing that was said
um so i think um you can get highly
expressive uh by callographers but to me
it's too expressive okay um it's a story
about
some some highly educated people looking
at a painting in the wall i think it was
an icon but i don't know what i thought
it was but they were just saying how
live it was and how wonderful it was
then a peasant lady was overhearing us
and she said
i couldn't help overhearing your
conversation and um
may i say something see of course you
know she said i don't think this is a
good icon because it's too alive
it's just too noisy it's too much full
of itself it's like a charismatic person
that swamps everyone else
and you think oh i'm a charismatic
person but it's just that person no one
else is in the room so that was
interesting it wasn't that quietness so
i think
that's amazing that theopharm the greek
you know he could be highly expressive
in his frescoes but then you look at his
panel paintings and he's really quite
gentle and quite highly worked there and
he knows how to be appropriate in each
situation
so i think it's it's really it's
sometimes difficult to get the balance
but yeah this is explicitness but
this could be quietness as well yeah so
you're not aware of
oh that artist is so free you know
you're not talking about the art rather
than the saints you know i want people
to forget my icons but if you're talking
about the same type of victim you know
that's the important thing that's when
you know it's working
no i i totally agree my i had the chance
of having my first experience at as a
commission you know i my bishop asked me
to make a panagia for him and that was
the first time i was getting a
commission i had no idea how to make
miniatures i had no you know i was just
just thrown into this and so i i found
someone a serbian carver that i had
exchanged with and he guided me through
making this this little thing and i was
so obsessed with the technical part of
it trying to get it right trying to you
know to have it you know and he he was
serbian this this iconographer uh george
belak
so he was ruthless with me he was just
ruthless he was he kept insulting me as
i was making the icon it was wonderful
uh and so i you know i worked on this i
made this thing and i brought it to uh
to my bishop
uh and all i was thinking about was if i
had done it properly and i he he he took
it he unwrapped the little icon and when
he saw it he crossed himself and he
bowed
and then i was just i was floored and i
realized okay this has very little to do
with me like
you know i am a vehicle for something
much bigger
and that's when it that's when i knew i
wanted to be an iconographer because i
thought you know picasso will sell his
work for millions and millions of
dollars but
no one will kiss his icons no one will
kiss his paintings no one will venerate
them and the only thing i have to give
up is the credit for that to happen and
i was like okay i'm willing to do that
and just be hopefully be as much as i
can a vehicle for
for the saints that are that are being
represented but uh yeah yeah that was
that was my first experience as a
commission
yeah and so i wanted to to um to shift a
little bit
and talk a bit about culture because
many of the people watching this are
people who are just interested in
culture where it's going
one of the things that we have in common
and that i've seen in your writing and
in your work is
a desire to not want to completely
oppose the world of sacred art and the
world of secularity of secular culture
but rather see them as
let's say say the sacred as the source
of the secular and the sacred as
something which can feed into other arts
and and become uh you know like a light
for for for culture and maybe i i know
people would love to hear you talk about
that a little bit
okay yes
yes it's interesting when i was a
sculptor um in new zealand before i
became orthodox i was looking for art
that helped express this sense of
otherness i mean i just wanted people
not to see a face that's interested in
faces primarily but i said we're the
spirit behind the face
and vancouver funny enough was always
into quite sort of um naturalistic
sculpture vancouver really um seemed to
be very profound and um i realized
gradually that behind the incredibly um
refined
word was actually the orthodox solicitor
he was actually a charger um in in the
in the orthodox choir he's romanian and
sort of rose out of the romanian
culture
and then you look at his uh endless
columns all these things
were actually rooted in in liturgical
culture the indus column was uh inspired
by indus columns which were over
gravestones so in memory of people that
was like the soul ascended to heaven
um
and the other thing that got me on this
track was the vision of ezekiel where he
has a vision of a temple
and an angel is showing him around and
then from underneath the altar the
temple runs a river and wherever the
river goes it brings life
so i thought well the worship of the
church the
the whole liturgical
symphony if you like is the source and
then
it's not a fountain that goes up in the
church and comes down again
it's a river that flows out into the
world and whether it goes in his life i
thought well if a culture is falling
apart it's because his worship
is blocked you know there's no river
flowing out
and so going back to vancouver a lot of
his aphorisms are to do with this he
said my studio in paris is just an
extension of the monastery and he names
the monastery of his village in romania
he talks about
simplicity of complexity resolved um all
these wonderful pearls of wisdom
sort of come out of that whole orthodox
culture
so um
i think with a lot of scholars beginning
to realize that
early 20th century modernism
abstractionism
actually had a religious inspiration and
you look at kandinsky again actually he
was russian a lot of his insiders from
um orthodoxy for him abstraction wasn't
to depart from reality we need to think
of abstraction as departure from reality
from it was to distort the essence to
abstract to draw out the essence of
something and depict it visually and
this is just what an icon does you know
you're indicating the fire of god within
um and then of course vancouver was the
father of um
a modern um abstract art convinced you
the father of modern
uh abstract painting um
and these came out of religious roots
then all that was forgotten and i'll be
to sort of
play around with this abstraction they'd
actually forget what they're trying to
do
whether one likes their art um that's
what they're trying to do to abstract
and reveal the invisible
so i i think um
deterred to call out and unfortunately
now a lot of zealot orthodoxy sort of
write off
in the other art but i think
healthy art um
in the world that isn't liturgical but
feeds the soul like doskieski's writing
i i think of his son this category i've
dubbed this um threshold out
it can help to bring us to the threshold
of the church
um
in fact the man who baptized me father
um ambrose in new zealand he came to
christ through doskiewski he was
studying um russian literature
um so he sort of wasn't ready to go into
the church in the fullness but he
touched the hymn of christ's government
by reading dostoevsky and then went
further and then looked up and there was
crying looking at him
and so how i'm curious to see
because i think a lot of people will see
that in principle let's say we'll see
that in principle uh and so are there
ways that you're
seeing this happen today are there some
places or some areas some art or some
literature that you feel that you're
or ways in which iconographers are able
to maybe help or feed into this because
i know a lot of people have that desire
and we see it like dostoyevsky is of
course an example but very few of us are
dostoevsky sadly um you know do you see
places in the world where this
connection can happen
of course the question i don't know
about places but it's more international
communities like i think orthodox arts
journal is really important because
it's trying to
work toward a fresh
uh
authentic understanding of tradition
but it's not exclusive in the sense that
it has this sort of openness to
liturgical art being eleven to inspire
healthy secular art in the positive
sense of the word
what i might call gallery art or
threshold art so i think
um not so much places it's it's sort of
places of culture of thinking of a way
of thinking in the individuals who can
be inspiring um there's a thing called
the orthodox arts festival which just
went online briefly and so they've got a
category for iconography a category for
also just writing you know so i i think
there are some writers there doing short
stories so i think there are online um
experimental bodies as it were for
people to try things out and get honest
feedback from other people
and it's all false outstanding has been
you know there's some openness for
genuine professional caring response to
people so you can iron sharp and zion as
it were um
i i've always had this long-term dream
of of a liturgical art
center where you're training people in
the church of a lot but also we have
conferences and meetings for those who
feel perhaps they're not called to be
literal artists but you know perhaps
they're composers like john tavin i knew
you said john taverner very well
um he wasn't really good at liturgical
music on the whole sometimes he got it
right but his role was actually to be in
the world and
as it would be like a horse of troy sort
of smuggle
the sacred and the profound
into the world um
so that's been my sort of dream i don't
think it happened in my own lifetime
i've worked with prince charles of it
and trying to have something happen and
my my literature to go out um
three-year part-time course as part of
that but i just love to have a
sense of it it's that buzz where people
can come and share ideas but like the
french cafe was during the 20th century
where they discuss ideas but
essential where there is a church where
there are different serious liturgical
training programs apprenticeships but
also we we have artists who are not as
orthodox but christians who feel that
their role is in the world
i think this i think this idea has been
buzzing around now for 10 years you know
and and i think that it's slowly
starting to show fruits you know in in
the us uh andrew gould is also working
on something similar the antiochians
here have this these ideas and so i i
think we just need to be patient and
slowly work towards something like that
uh happening you know
um
people have also talked about here we
know people talk a lot about terence
malik as a place also where this type of
there's with his recent movie a hidden
life where you really get this this
desire to create uh i don't know to
visually show in a movie a
a christian experience you know so i
think i think that there are definitely
places where
where this is happening now um i guess
i'm gonna turn the tables a little bit
and ask you
there's also a very experimental
iconography going on right now and so on
the one hand we have this sense that
that uh liturgical art and the power of
of our traditions can infuse popular
culture but there's also the the things
happening both ways and so i obviously i
don't want to name iconographers this is
it's important to i want to avoid
polemics but do you i've seen a lot of
icons that present themselves of icons
but go very far in integrating either
modernist or even postmodern aesthetics
you know um
effect i would call it something like
that and so do you feel like sometimes
that can also
go too far or do you see it as a
sometimes i see it as a laboratory like
this this is bubbling on the edges and
it's not going to continue it's just
going to be idiosyncratic but a little
bit of it will enter into a tradition
and follow the kind of enter into the
stream but i don't know if you have some
perceptions about that type of work
happening
yeah it's a very important point to
raise it jonathan i think
the two sides to it i think there needs
to be a certain
freedom and fearlessness and
experimenting
um it means what spirit that
experimenting has done you know is it to
show off my ego or am i genuinely trying
to make literal art iconography
composing whatever it is that helps
people get closer to christ
um but because i wanted to be authentic
um you know i've got to try some
different things so that's fine that's
fine i think life in christ shouldn't be
dominated by fear um and you throw these
things out there and if they're not
quite right they'll just buy a natural
death i think there is a part for
certain
a place of certain experimentation on
the other hand i think um
you get to certain point
we experimenting with things that you're
playing with fire you know experiment as
an artist
that don't put it in front of people
saying no you try to pray with us you
know so i think
i think some iconography there i just
think it's just too it's great i
appreciate it as art but
don't pretend it's an icon i think it's
just going a bit too far so i think um
on the one hand you're people who say
iconography is not art i think it is art
it's much more than that but it's at
least out in other words it should have
a beauty or harmony
but then some of this contemporary
economics i think is just getting a bit
too
um
arty and lovely as art um you can't
it can't be taken a case-by-case basis i
think
um
and so one of one of the things that i
think is happening and this is difficult
because
you know we have we have a sense the
modern man has uh
has a feeling you could call it you know
the the shock of the new or the the
effect of novelty and that the effect of
novelty has a surprising element like
when you see it it surprises you and it
creates a certain
a certain sense that a certain sense of
wonder you could call it and to be fair
to it and so i think that what i'm
seeing at a lot of the a lot of the more
experimental iconography there's a
danger to confuse let's say this deeper
this deeper encounter that you talked
about the stillness of encounter with
the icon uh to confuse the
experience of shock of the new and this
kind of surprise because it's there's an
elation in that surprise uh and it makes
you want to even on the in the online
word world especially because you want
to get attention and so you people will
share an image of an icon which is
slightly askew because it'll be able to
gather get people's attention quickly as
they're scrolling down their facebook
feed uh and so i to me i i see that
there is a little bit of a danger to
confuse the
the the experience of novelty with the
deeper you know
encounter with the sacred the sacred i
don't know what you think of that i
think
if we look at nature
um things adapt by very slow increments
you know if if environment changes
you'll find that nature begins to adapt
slowly
bit by bit yeah there's a mutation most
mutations
i i'm not useful but the odd one is
useful
they really do get something you know
there's a bird suddenly grow four wings
um so i i think in our time um we need
to move toward a more more authentic
western iconography by small increments
that's how i approach it you know i'm
not a particularly great painter myself
i've got to move very slowly and
gradually gradually i adapt
um there are some people far better than
i you can can can can move more quickly
but it's just my insufficiency but i
disagree with really small increments um
and and i i think you know some of the
works as you suggest are
just a bit bit too shocking really
they're just jumping too far ahead of
themselves as well
um but on the other hand i think just to
do mindless copying
it might be safer but i think it's a bit
dangerous because basically we're saying
life with christ is well it's like the
the man who buried his talent he buried
was he was afraid
exactly risk you know they they invested
their two talents five talents they took
a risk it might have failed
but they thought well you know this my
master trusts me with this money
so he must believe in me so i'm going to
take a risk and invest it and hopefully
it will increase and it did but the one
who only had one he was afraid and he
buried it and he was told off
so i think just mindless copying is
actually acting out of fear
and it's it's fascinating because the we
talked about the world of technology as
creating this mosaic of of images you
know and this this constant novelty and
this constant change that that it's
difficult for not to attract us but the
same technology is what is making it
possible for people to just slavishly
copy
you know 16th century russian art
because we have these high resolution
pictures that people can have in front
of them as they're working you know the
ancient medieval artists couldn't
couldn't stand there in front of these
amazing images and just copy them you
know to the letter they had to to draw
them from afar and then bring them into
the studio and you know and so this was
that would create a just a natural
transformation without it without a
desire to be in to create innovation it
would just happen on its own because you
can't completely remember the thing you
saw in the cathedral right yeah exactly
yeah but to internalize it they saw it
for half an hour then three months later
that he get back home and they're
painted so they'd have to internalize
that image and of course that would mean
that they were translating and i've done
some translating from greek into english
and
it's quite a creative act you know
you're translating um a content rather
than a word
and so one of the things that you've
also been known for i think that you
know we we talk about you as an
iconographer as an icon cover but you
your your work spans much more than that
you you've designed churches you design
liturgical objects you're really more
a liturgical designer and so i'd like to
know a little bit about how you see this
coming together because there's
something
there's something different about let's
say designing a reliquary or designing a
a church and the icon itself and so
maybe you can speak a little bit to how
this these different languages come
together in in the experience of
orthodoxy in uh like
as a european like as an english person
you know to to be able to create these
these spaces that are
you know you've created iconostasis with
icons on them and i've seen you done
everything from a bishop staff to
to uh you know to reliquaries uh
how do you decide or how do you kind of
pull in your different influences when
you are creating things
um
i suppose i start with place first you
know where's this place i've done work
for a church in
madrid and another in amsterdam so for
example the stone icon screen i made the
church of saint nicholas and amsterdam
there are lots of different cultures
there
so in the um
the roughly one meter by one meter three
foot by three foot stone plaques and
then with the icons
i made designs that reflected the
different cultures there against
anglo-saxon there was something more
from the netherlands something that was
russian something was greek so i start
with the actual place i think place is
important you know the gods and kind of
in that place
um and and the fire of of of the burning
bush is in that particular bush you know
it's it's it it wasn't a bush bought in
from england that was that moses saw it
was a
it was an egyptian bush that was burning
um so i researched the um the art of
that culture um
suppose this is um where discernment is
quite required you know what what is
usable in that culture what isn't um a
slight deviation but it does express
what i'm saying that said nicolas of
japan to my mind is the great one of the
great
missionaries because for seven years
he just studied japanese culture you
know and he really gained
got a respect for it
so after about seven years he began to
speak to people about the faith
and then when japanese converted they
realized that they're actually
converting to christ not to being a
russian he was able to
embed the faith in
japan
so but all that required quite a bit of
research and an appreciation of the
japanese culture so that's the first
thing research really
um and secondly
this object it might be relictly
whatever's i realize it can be part of a
larger symphony and it's got to work
with that symphony
and i think this is why i got involved
in so many different
media that i feel i'm here to serve the
church serve christ and the worship
and
that requires a certain unity of worship
and i think we suffer too much from
yeah this iconographer then put an icon
painting in the ward and you get a
another person from another place to do
the icon screen it doesn't fit but you
know he he's remaining sort of romanian
one or whatever he's drinks he'll do a
greek screen so get this completely
credible mishmash and this upsets me you
know i feel there's no just
aesthetically you know no attempt to
make the uniform
a beautiful thing that dances together
you know everyone's just
jamming doing your own thing it's
cacophony
um so i think it's out of that that has
felt compelled to try to you know
respond to the need and get involved in
different media
um
i'm actually going to be working on a
novel sin partially out of the desire to
create a church i probably would never
be able to design and and make a whole
church so in this novel it's all about
this process of this man who's
um
[Music]
who whose uncle is according to the
reading of his will and the uncle
was a very wealthy man
and he made a vow to god to build a
church um but he got cancer and he knows
he's not gonna have time to build it so
in his world he says to his um
his nephew i'm giving all my wealth to
you um as long as you build a church
this church for this monastery and then
you can have the rest of the money and
the whole novel goes on about the
process of him and other people changing
in the process of not just building a
building but decorating it inside
um
so yeah i suppose the basis of it is
that you're not just creating an
individual art object but you're
creating a symphony and that symphony
is an improvisation in the sense that
god just doesn't drop from him and a
complete score and jordan was just a
player
he he sets a sort of theme and you
improvise on that
so yeah
you're going to improvise in canada in a
different way
this from the same sort of
um
not tuned but the same theme that christ
has given to us both yeah there's
definitely i i love the images you use i
think that
really theme and variation is exactly
the way to to to see it you know and
that there is this there has always been
because we
we're so polar in the way we think you
know we we tend to think of tradition as
something which is completely solid and
completely fixed
and then we have the idea of the modern
world which is idiosyncratic and
improvisational but when you look at
like you said the great iconographers
you see
this strange play between the messiness
and uh you know and a desire to be in
tune with the
the inner music let's say or the hidden
music
um
one of the biggest difficulties i think
one of the biggest questions this is a
very practical question but it it's not
it does there's also something
theological in the question let's say is
that many of us like let's say example
of the parish where i am you know the
parish where we are we are renting from
a catholic church
and
so we have this space which is a 1960s
catholic church you can imagine you know
what that means
um
and we we're taking over from a romanian
church that was there before and you
know for all my love of them and respect
of them they put up an iconostasis which
is
as if like an extraterrestrial
ship had come down you know it's baroque
you know it's highly ornamented and it's
spray-painted and it has you know all of
that and so
what is your advice to people who are in
spaces which are not
liturgically conducive in the outset how
can you
what kind of advice you have for people
who are in spaces that are ugly or that
are look like strip malls or you know
how is it that you can without
like i said without creating this
strange disjunct you know how can we
adapt our
our work to to these kinds of spaces
sorry for the hard question oh yeah
i think this place is going to be taken
in the same mirrors and sometimes it's
damaged limitations of this probably
more from the not as damaged limitation
it's probably impossible to make
something really beautiful but i think
the first principle is
be appropriate to space you know don't
force it to be something that it isn't
it's one parish i know where they they
bought a methodist church which is
just a rectangle really
um
no i think they should have treated that
a bit like a basilica you know but what
they did was they created inside
um
a four column dome church at a
plasterboard you know and once you're if
you're blindfolded and walk in i thought
it's really nice
you go outside well that's rather weird
um so i think that that was being
dishonest to what was there it would
have been better to think okay this is
like a basilica um
basically a rectangle let's work with
that you know um so i think authenticity
so if it is just a 1960s
white wall
geometrical thing or circle whatever it
is then well let's make the best of that
there's a limitation but let's make the
limitation our strength i think that's
surprising to listen i think
often we don't listen enough to the
space you know we just jump in and do
what we saw down in greece romania
so i think listen a lot if you just
worship in a place look at it and think
okay well
you know what can this split place teach
me you know what are strengths it's
weaknesses how can i capitalize not just
be one strength
um how can i capitalize on that um
beyond that
i think that's all i can say at the
moment
yeah
it's gotta take each place as it goes
sometimes you can put it in reverse and
take things out um that can be a
pastoral challenge because
um
we've always had that and you know joe
blogs gave it to us and has been
insulting to take it out so that's a job
of the priest ready to really gradually
educate the feast
the icon skin i made for amsterdam the
priest was brilliant there he i think a
lot of the russians were expecting a
high russian screen
so about the year before we we did the
work he had in the back a whole and head
talks and all that about the history of
the icon screen and you had this display
in the back with photographs
so gradually people realized actually
the russian icon screen with five
stories was actually quite a late thing
so in fact you know having this
one layered screen is actually quite
traditional
so there's often a lot of education that
is needed patient education
into history more often than not not
just theology but history you know how's
the church from the past dealt with us
so education and humility and listening
i think are things that can all help
yeah yeah well thank you because i think
this is at least in america it's
definitely a struggle that many parishes
have because you know we end up in these
very odd spaces and
the temptation to create you know for
example like you said to have a flat
ceiling but then put a sticker of of
christ pantocrator you know and on the
ceiling
uh even
sometimes it's even a low it's not very
high you know it's not that high
it's like 12 feet high but there's this
there's this you know
instead of really kind of but it's hard
because the space is ugly so when you
say listen it's difficult we don't want
to you know because we we actually don't
have a lot of love for the space but i i
seen what you're saying really even in a
way maybe
the way to approach popular culture in
general or or modern culture which is
that
in order this is something that that i
think that in order for something to
exist there has to be at least some seed
there has to be there has to be some
seed which is making it exist and so if
we're
patient and attentive and we we watch we
can find these little
these little these little sparks let's
say sometimes they're very small and
sometimes they're very hard to find but
they they kind of have to be there or
else yeah or else we we wouldn't even be
able to perceive it you know
but i think um
sometimes we've got to acknowledge that
one generation is not beyond salvation
but you're not going to find much good
on that so you've got to think ahead
what about the next generation so what
i'm talking about future
purpose-built orthodox architecture
and at the moment most of the orthodox
churches i've seen in america just don't
work you know they put our orthodox
students got to do they put a dome on
they've got archers instead of archers
but we don't understand at all what
we're doing
acoustically for example i when i was
doing work in um houston texas i was
talking to a priest there about domes
and he said not one purpose-built
orthodox church ever been through in
this country which has good acoustics
you know and you see we don't know
out of our hubris we haven't really
studied byzantine churches properly
um and but i did read a very good um
article by an orthodox man who's
acoustic engineer for nasa he knows his
stuff and this article was outlining
some principles of
acoustics and often they're surprising
you know right angles is not a good
thing flat floors isn't a good thing
i think one of the reasons why we're
finding it difficult to make successful
contemporary architecture is the
materials we use
unfortunately concrete is here to stay
but um with stone you've got to have a
notch if you want to have you know a
roof that's out of stone you could have
an arch so all these shapes arose out of
the weakness of the materials
um and they're natural and they work
well the concrete doesn't necessarily
need an art sometimes you do but
something we've got this material
reinforced culture that's really strong
it doesn't have many limitations
um but we pretend that it's something
that it doesn't so i think we need to
think ahead
and figure out well what are the
principles of good orthodox architecture
so what can be changed
what makes
makes most old orthodox architecture
work consistently
so we need to be thinking one or two
generations of here do you really get
serious about this
you know orthodox church is an orthodoxy
so it's got a dream on top
um and i think we really need to look
into this um and do some serious
thinking and um
yeah we've got a lot
even in terms of culture i think what
you're saying is true that is
there's you know i i there's something
this is i get this is one of the reasons
why we started the orthodox arts journal
at the outset is that we realize that it
was the seminarians
that we had to talk to in a way that
that we wanted to create something a
vehicle
of uh
to show them to show beauty to show
adaptation to show all these things and
our target was not
so much the older priest would thank
thank god if they if they can hear it
but it was really to affect the
seminarians so that you know ten and
we're seeing it now you know andrew
gould
if ten years ago
you know was within the balance of his
work he was struggling to get liturgical
commissions now
he he gets them there he has to refuse
them you know and so you can see that
the transformation
is slowly happening of course it's not
it's not complete there's still a lot of
work to do but we can see the
the fruits of the seeds that we planted
and that you planted you know you know
10 years ago 15 years ago are starting
to
to appear in the culture and so
i think there's a lot to be grateful for
that
yes i was approached by um the
chancellor of chichester cathedral a
major cathedral in the south of england
to help them start at a surgical arts
center
um so i said that's fine i i myself
can't do a lot with the practical
training of the technical artist wasn't
just icons the whole thing but my two
apprentices um they can go down and be
the core of the practical training but i
said
i don't want us just to look at training
the legitimacy but i want to look at
training future priests
well ideally also contemporary priests
but most of them already set in their
ways because
the commissioners need to be educated i
see it as much as the
makers of the typical art because
hey a lot of them don't realize the
importance of putting her to go out they
think they do to go out of just
getting a painter to paint something
that's of a sacred subject but
it's it's how it's done which has fixed
the soul as much as what is done
like you can't you know sing the psalms
to rock music and liturgy it might be
great rock music but it doesn't help
prayer same words but have the same
words to byzantine and gregorian chant
have a different effect on the soul
so you've got to train the commissioners
which is basically the priests and i
think they've got to go hand in hand i'm
just
astounded that
orthodox priests and anglican and
catholic have all told me the same thing
that their seminarian training
doesn't have any compulsory training in
in liturgical art or literal beauty i
thought you know what converted russia
you know that's right exactly first of
all to orthodoxy it's normally some
aspect of the beauty of it that's the
fragrance then they find where does this
fragrance come from but the thing that
stimulates in longing is beauty but
you've got nothing there in the
liturgical in in the seminarian training
i think something's wrong here
so this needs to be facing every
theological academy to have a compulsory
at least one day you know after three
years one day please where you give them
a taste of the importance of literal art
i think that's i think that's so true uh
and there is a these there's here in
america we're kind of seeing a little
bit i don't know how it's integrated
into the semi the seminars but we're
seeing you know saying vladimir is
developing this
this arts uh kind of
art center that i mean it's not it's not
a practical it's more theoretical but
that's okay because they're priests you
know a and you can see it at centicons
as well they want to have a kind of art
center so i think it's ver it's coming
it's burgeoning uh but we yeah we
definitely need to encourage it and to
all you
i know a lot of seminarians will be
watching this you know you need to put
pressure on your own seminaries as well
you know to make sure that you're able
to to get
a uh
and like aiden said the
you know i'm seeing it the people that
are attracted to orthodoxy through the
things that i'm saying it really is the
beauty which is attracting them you know
the beauty you know of the scriptures
the beauty of how this integrates into
liturgical life you know these these
powerful patterns that show us that the
world is meaningful that the world is is
actually leading us towards god if we
are capable of engaging with it and
paying attention to it in the proper
manner and so so you know
i think you're completely right
i um when i was in my hermitage at
priest i came with his parishioners to
talk about things and
i didn't deliberately said something i
knew that which would shock the priest
and i said to the the parishioners look
and they're all converts forget about
orthodoxy it's life with christ you know
orthodox is just a name
orthodox and all that i mean i know
orthodoxy is is the fullness of the
truth but it's the thing is that you're
a human being before god forget all the
oxys and the isms
and beauty this is thinking of beauty it
doesn't have an ism or an optism it's
the beauty affects your soul profoundly
i remember when i um was doing up the
hermitage it was run down this 20 acres
of property and had to do a lot of work
on it and
i converted half the barn into a chapel
and frescoed it and um
made a wooden mosaic floor and and such
like anyway there's still work to be
done and the i'd get
10 tons of gravel delivered or sand and
there's one day this big truck comes up
and it's a really wild place it's up in
the hills this big muscly man with
tattoos all over delivers the truck and
he delivers the sand and he said what
are you doing here i said i'm making him
hermited
i said i'll show you the chapel and this
guy sort of walks into the chapel
and he just stood there
it didn't say anything i saw he began to
cry you know just began to weave
and i didn't say anything you know he
wasn't a religious man i think but it
just just touched him just beauty
touched him so it's just one person
he didn't know about orthodoxy anything
it didn't matter you know he met god in
that place
so i think we just have to go back to
the basics you know it's all to do with
life as a human being on this earth and
god's wonderful creation
loving god and beauty is the fragrance
that comes out of that loving one
another and loving christ
well aidan i think that's a really
wonderful place to to uh to finish our
conversation thank you so much for
the encouragement and for your wisdom
and also thank you for your work you
know i i know how much influence you
have and you know you you remain you
remain humble and uh
and discreet but i know that so many
iconographers have been influenced by
you and not just that but just as a
person you know for me as well i want to
thank you for the
the advice you gave me at the outset you
know when i started and just knowing
that you were there i could always send
you things when i was when i was
struggling with some images i've always
sent you you know some some carvings to
get your opinion and and even sometimes
you've been harsh on me with some you
might not remember but there's sometimes
when you said you know stop doing it
this way and i was like well you know
i think he's right and so i've actually
changed the way that i carved because of
your advice and so thank you for thank
you for also talking to
the people for i'm happy that people are
able to discover you a little more
everybody that's watching this please
go online you will find several books by
ayden you if you go on amazon you will
you will discover his writing his work
on the orthodox art journal there's
several articles by him and also you'll
see some of his projects so aidan thank
you for your time and and for being here
with me
thank you so much it's been a joy to
talk with you